[Music]
ah
[Music]
hahaha
[Music]
so
hey
huh
[Music]
when you go home
tell them of us and say
for your tomorrow we gave our today
um
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
well live images there from around the
nation as the united kingdom marks
remembrance day uh including uh here at
the cop summit where we saw alex sharma
uh the minister in charge of cop uh
joined
by
the
secretary general of the united nations
and uh uh to mark that
now uh at the national memorial
arboretum in staffordshire at the
cenotaph uh and at the the duke and
duchess of gloucester along with
representatives from the ministry of
defense the royal navy the royal air
force and the royal british legion all
laid wreaths
ahead of remembrance sunday
this weekend where of course there will
be events
at
the cenotaph
and around the country at war memorials
let's go to our correspondent lisa dowd
who is at that national memorial uh
arboretum uh in staffordshire uh lisa
as ever on these annual events a very
somber atmosphere
as the uh ceremony continues here in
staffordshire it is perhaps poignant to
reflect on the sixteen thousand names
which surround the people who are
gathered here they're etched into
the stone here on this memorial the
sixteen thousand names of service men
and women who've lost their lives since
world war ii either
on duty or as a result of a terrorist
act and quite sobering to think
that actually there is space on this
memorial for 15 000 more names and i was
speaking earlier to a world war ii
veteran 96 years old he has come here
today
to remember those lost but he told me
the story of his twin brother
who he had thought been killed in world
war ii he thought that for two and a
half years and then he had the elation
of finding out that he had actually
survived and then the deflation of
realizing that he was terribly injured
and he was going to carry those injuries
with him for the rest of his life and
that veteran was here with his son also
a veteran who had looked on these walls
and found the name of a friend a comrade
who had also
fallen and he was very upset reflecting
on the loss of his friend and then to
more recent years the last name carved
into the stone here is that of a service
woman who died in 2020 a brodie gillen
lance corporal and she was a reserve
army medic and she was killed in a
rocket attack in iraq along with two u.s
troops so
everybody here reflecting through the
years and and remembering those who have
lost their lives in service
lisa lisadao thank you very much indeed
for joining us
well back here